first to another critical topic tonight
the left's push to further their radical
agenda by packing the supreme court
with liberal justices take a listen
the republicans stole two seats on the
supreme court
and now it is up to us to repair that
damage we must expand the court
and we must abolish the filibuster to do
it
some people will say we're packing the
court we're not packing it we're
unpacking it
senator lindsey graham joins me now to
react to that and much more good evening
senator graham thanks so much for being
with us
first question to you thank you uh when
they say the supreme court is broken and
they need to fix
it what are these people talking about
uh it's conservative and they want it to
be liberal
there's nothing broken about the supreme
court there are nine justices
it's been that way for since the 1869
i think they want to turn the court
upside down to pack it with liberals
because they don't like the makeup of
the court and what will happen
is that every time one party takes over
from the other we'll change the number
of justices you've been a lawyer all
your life
it will destroy the rule of law as we
know this is the biggest assault
on the rule of law and the independent
judiciary in my lifetime
the idea of packing the court so
liberals can make it
liberal rather than changing the makeup
through the
election process the way we've done it
for a long time so
this is a very dramatic bold move and
i'll do everything in my power
to stop it in the senate because it
would destroy the supreme court as we
know it
it would become a political football
well there's no question it would be
just another political branch of
government
you know in in the party of whichever
party is in power
and even ruth bader ginsburg said that
it was a bad idea
to pack the court but and they can rule
on
anything they can rule on the second
amendment
uh on on abortion on
unions on any one of a number of issues
it doesn't matter
yeah the court matters to our lives yeah
okay quit to all of us i want to move on
for a second because there's a lot of
news now today
president biden uh said for the first
time
that the uh that there was a crisis at
the border i think we have some sound on
them
we had the problem was that the refugees
was working
well you know it's not real clear what
he's talking about but he had initially
said
uh that they were going to cap the
refugees coming across at 15
000. aoc has a connection and then he
changes his mind
and he actually admits that there's a
crisis on the border what do you think
of
well it's not a crisis it's chaos i was
down there just a few weeks ago
we had 172 000 people come into the
country illegally in march alone we're
on track to do
2 million the border patrol told the
biden administration during the
transition
if you reverse trump policies there'll
be a run on the border they were right
i've never been more worried than am now
about the world at large
writ large you've got the russians
threatening to go into ukraine
you got the chinese threatening taiwan
the border is completely out of control
we're going to withdraw completely from
afghanistan and
make sure the taliban take care of al
qaeda and isis that's insane
so joe biden is has created a lot of
instability in a very short period of
time
and if he doesn't change his policies on
the border the yet is work
the worse is yet to come if you dig it
doesn't get tougher with the iranians
they're going to have a bomb before you
know it
i'm really worried about the world under
the biden administration
they're clueless in my view in terms of
the threats we face
at the border and abroad
well let's talk about specifically
afghanistan i know you feel very
strongly about it
um there are 2 2 500
military forces there why are you so
against removing them
well they're an insurance policy against
another 911 the
the last time we ignored afghanistan we
had 3 000 americans killed
afghanistan was a safe haven for al
qaeda they planned the attacks against
our country there
have we learned nothing from iraq when
we withdraw from these places
and don't have an insurance policy
residual force to watch the bad guys
they come back here if you don't have
your foot on their throat over there
they're coming back here if you don't
find in their backyard they're going to
come back to our backyard
this is the 20th anniversary 911. we had
three or four thousand folks on the
ground over there al qaeda and isis
could never regenerate to attack the
united states i think what he's done
biden has left us naked we're now
depending on
one group of tariffs to police another
group of terrorists i'm very worried
that we're going to pay a heavy price
for leaving afghanistan
like we did in iraq but it's going to be
worse they're going to come roaring back
and we're going to have to go back in
and we're putting our homeland at risk
if you don't believe me believe the
military he was advised not to do
this in iraq he did it he was advised
not to do it
in afghanistan and he did it anyway and
he was told by the border patrol
don't change trump policies you'll lose
control of the border
he constantly turns down sound advice to
the detriment of our country
and i'm very worried about the state of
the world under joe biden
all right senator lindsey graham thanks
so much for being with us tonight we
appreciate your insight thank you